finally some hogwarts legacy news and
possibly coming soon question mark well
clearly that is what a large number of
you believe based on all the responses
that i have seen over the past week
regarding the latest promo email from wb
games but sadly guys that i hate to be
the one to do this i hate to be the one
but i don't think this email means what
so many are taking it to mean i do not
believe that hogwarts legacy news is
imminent or that it's about to happen
soon we're going to take a look at this
email in its entirety and i'm going to
explain why i think that now before we
jump into this though i do want to say
thank you to all those who tweeted this
to me i really do appreciate when people
send me news tips like this because at
first i actually had not received this
email i saw a couple people talking
about it some people tweeted it at me so
i really do appreciate that if you guys
ever see anything like that you think
would make a good hogwarts legacy video
or maybe something you think i haven't
seen yet feel free to tweet it to me at
retrorecontour now before we go any
further i also want to say that this is
my opinion here i could be totally wrong
about this now i do have a little bit of
experience here which we're going to
talk about as we get into the video but
this is all just my guess and my
interpretation of this email because
clearly what it is it is a promo email
and i have a background in marketing and
communications and so sadly i think what
is happening here is people are kind of
misinterpreting exactly what this email
newsletter is saying and it's partially
because of how this email newsletter is
organized so let's just start right here
at the top we've got the little wb games
header with some of their properties at
the top on the far right we see a
hippogriff which of course is from the
wizarding world but i don't think it's
from hogwarts legacy it actually looks
like it might be from that other port
key games magic awakened or possibly
harry potter hogwarts mystery but it
doesn't really matter which specific
game it's from clearly it's there to
represent the harry potter franchise and
its overall part in wb games now so
let's scroll down and we see this
heading here that says sneak peek at
what's coming in september so you can
clearly see that this is a heading for
everything that's about to come below it
and this is one of the early points of
some confusion because i get it some
people see that and you think oh well
everything in this email this is what's
coming in september but let's kind of
look through it here and i think you'll
see that that's not really the case so
the first one immediately under that
heading pre-order and get the fort hope
elite weapon skin pack for back for
blood of course that makes sense then
you have right here on the bottom right
this pre-order now button so we got the
heading above it and then we have the
pre-order now button below now we have a
thin blue line there that then takes us
into game of thrones conquest and at the
bottom of that one it says play now it's
ready to go so you don't have to
pre-order anything that one you can play
now then we have another thin blue line
and then i believe this is like
injustice 2 mobile or something defeat
boss dark darkseid before it's too late
then you have that same divider at the
bottom right that we saw back up here at
the top with back for blood only on this
one it says play now again no pre-order
needed keep going below that we have
mortal kombat mobile double challenge
here and then again play now now we've
got the thin blue line again and then we
have a brand new heading so to me this
is a clear separation point for
everything above so everything above is
what they were talking about for
september now we go below that coming
soon and we have another subheading
which says dc fandom is back then we've
got the picture there and then we have
the register at the bottom right so dc
fandom we already know the date it's
going to be october 16th all of that
kind of fits in there with that dc
fandom is back and then the register
right there now below that we have
another sub heading that says don't miss
an update yet it also falls under the
coming soon and below that don't miss an
update we have hogwarts legacy along
with a subscribe button if you hit that
subscribe button it just takes you to
the official hogwarts legacy webpage
where you can sign up for what i believe
is this email newsletter so for starters
here i don't think you should expect any
sort of update in september to me that
is clearly defined by what is above the
coming soon header i also don't think
you should expect any sort of update on
hogwarts legacy at the dc fandom that
just doesn't make sense that's not a
place where i would expect to see any
kind of hogwarts legacy news again this
is just totally my opinion here i'm not
saying it's impossible i just wouldn't
personally expect it so then what we're
left to wrestle with here in terms of
hogwarts legacy is this coming soon
header which i think clearly applies to
it and then the don't miss an update so
when they say coming soon obviously how
soon right i mean dc fandom is about a
month from now so i guess they're
considering that to be relatively soon i
mean soon could be in one month soon
could be in two months soon could be in
three months right it's very nebulous
and when i first saw this i have to
admit i thought it was just sort of a
generic kind of don't miss an update not
like they have a specific update in mind
but just more of a marketing thing like
don't miss any of our updates that we
have subscribe to the newsletter here
now the other thing it doesn't tell us
is what type of update this is it could
literally be a screenshot it could be a
few lines of text it could be a new
trailer we really have no idea so i have
learned my lesson from the playstation
showcase event i am not getting my hopes
up if we get anything at all on a
hogwarts legacy before the end of the
year i will be pleasantly surprised i
mean to me it is pretty clear that this
don't miss an update is falling under
the coming soon header but again it's
like how soon is soon right and then the
button that they have associated with
that one isn't a pre-order isn't a play
now obviously it's not a register it's a
subscribe for the newsletter so
ultimately i think what it comes down to
here is do you believe the way this is
phrased that they have a specific
hogwarts legacy update in mind that they
are talking about when they say don't
miss an update or is it just one of the
games that they haven't mentioned yet in
this list and so they're like hey we
don't really know when something is
coming on this but let's put in a little
subscribe button here so whenever there
is something you'll get the update
whenever it happens and i gotta be
honest that second one is what i was
leaning toward but the more i look at
this i mean it really does seem like the
hogwarts legacy is falling under the
coming soon this email of course has
also made it over to the harry potter
game subreddit which is the hogwarts
legacy subreddit and several of the
comments actually the top comments are
from folks who work in marketing not
specifically for hogwarts legacy or wb
or anything like that but they're folks
with marketing backgrounds and all three
of them there are three at the top there
that talk about how they think that it
does fall under coming soon but it
absolutely does not fall under what's
coming in september so i'm curious to
see what you guys think about this email
do you think this means an update is
imminent do we have one coming right
around the corner or is it a little bit
more nebulous and kind of like hey
they're kind of hoping they'll have
something to show us before the end of
the year you guys already know this is
one i would absolutely love to be wrong
on i hope we get new information as soon
as possible i can't wait to hear more
about this game as always thank you all
so much for watching i'll talk to you
again soon